[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr gute kollegen
der aktionsplan zur förderung der
geschlechtlichen liefert der grünen von
gestern zeigt wohin sie wollen in einem
satz
dieser aktionsplan ist die ausgeburt
grüne allmachtsfantasien aus einer
dekadenten abgehobenen parallelwelten
bahn anbieten die mit dem realen
problemen der bürger nichts mehr zu tun
haben
bemerkenswert es nicht was die grünen
zur homophobie und transphobie sagen sie
adressieren natürlich ihren politischen
lieblingsfeind die populisten und
nationalisten und die neokonservativen
der übliche hoogland der merkens wert
ist aber was sie bei alledem zu dem
thema homophobie nicht sagen ich gebe
ihnen einen tipp es sind nicht die
populisten die nationalisten oder die
neokonservativen die homosexuelle
steinigen köpfen oder von dächern werfen
sie haben in ihrer presseerklärung zwar
zu recht auf das himmel schreiende
unrecht hingewiesen dass homosexuelle in
einigen ländern mit dem tode bedroht
werden was sie nicht gesagt haben ist in
welchen ländern es in pakistan
afghanistan iran irak saudi arabien
katar die vereinigten arabischen emirate
sodann mauretanien jemen somalia syrien
und brunei was haben alle diese staaten
gemeinsam erstens alle diese staaten
stehen auch auf der liste von open doors
der christenverfolgung in allen ländern
wo homosexuelle mit dem tode bedroht
werden werden auch christen verfolgt und
zweitens alle diese staaten sind
muslimisch wenn in einem land
homosexuelle die todesstrafe droht dann
gibt es eine 100 prozentige
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür dass dort auch
christen verfolgt werden und dass es
sich um ein muslimisches land handelt
dieser befund alleine
steht für sich dritte gemeinsamkeit das
sind die staaten aus denen die
überwiegende anzahl der migranten im
moment zu uns kommt nachdem grundstücken
gerne schnell noch sehr viel mehr um zu
sehen was das für einen einfluss auf
westeuropa haben wird schauen wir uns
großbritannien an
im landesdurchschnitt sagen dort 15
prozent homosexualität ist moralisch
falsch da wenn sie sagen na klar da wo
diese populistischen nationalistischen
neokonservativen black city anhänger
hausen kein wunder dass ist das klischee
aber schauen sie auf die zahlen
in london sind es 29 prozent die
homosexualität als moralisch falsch
betrachten fast doppelt so viel im
bunten weltoffenen von labour regierten
london denen doppelt so viele menschen
homosexualität ab wie im ländlichen
christlichen konservativen ergeben warum
ist das nur so schauen sie sich die
zahlen einfach an wie hoch der anteil
der muslime in london ist an ist dann
haben sie die antwort und die mehrheit
der muslime den promo sexualität
übrigens nicht nur als moralisch falsch
es geht weit darüber hinaus 52 prozent
der britischen muslime sagen nicht nur
um sexualität es moralisch falsch
sondern homosexualität sollte verboten
werden 52 prozent der britischen muslime
sondern ist heute schon da wo berlin das
ruhrgebiet und köln
bald sein werden nach berechnungen des
pew research centers wird sich bei
fortgesetzter einwanderungen der anteil
der muslime in deutschland in den
kommenden jahren auf 20 prozent bei uns
erhöhen in vielen städten und gemeinden
sind sie dann die mehrheit und der islam
kennt keine
minderheitenrechte das sind die dunklen
wolken die über die homosexuellen in
westeuropa heraufziehen aber die wollen
sie die grünen trommler für die multi
kulti republik natürlich nicht sehen
weil er die zerstörung der
christlich-abendländischen kultur viel
wichtiger ist als das was danach kommt
auch wenn es der abgrund ist die grünen
reden lieber über diversität sensible
sport und freizeit angeordnet über
programme für die mediale repräsentanz
lesbischer mädchen und über geschlechter
sensibilisierungs programme für die
polizei alles aus ihrem antrag das sind
die modethemen ihrer klientel der
hipster der latte macchiato und
mandelmilch linken sie und ihre anhänger
sollten endlich erwachsen werden und der
bitteren realität ins auge sehen wenn
die fahne des halbmondes steigt wird die
fahne des regenbogens rennen es ist nur
eine frage der zeit und der demografie
der homosexuelle schützen will braucht
keine diversity strategie der braucht
eine strategie gegen die islamisierung
unseres landes und ob es ihnen passt
oder nicht die einzige partei die die
islamisierung deutschlands verhindern
will
das ist die fdp
[Applaus]